dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi tout
cela est arrivé qu'une étape sidération
puisque pour la des millions de birmans
a vraiment l'impression qu'on a fait un
saut dans le passé de 10 ans en arrière
[Musique]
pour roxane souche ici pour la détention
d'un pauvre deux hôpitaux qui en vertu
d'une vieille loi très orwélienne sur
les télécommunications
le président qui est incarcéré pour une
fraude électorale dont tout cela s'est
vraiment très familier pour le peuple
birman toute cette propagande d'état
militaire où on ne recule devant rien
[Musique]
il ya une dizaine d'années ce qu'on a
appelé un peu trop précocement le
printemps gamme en cette période de
transition démocratique qui se met un
peu en retrait en mettant en avant un
gouvernement civil mais ils ont renforcé
leur pouvoir leur prérogative leurs
revenus aussi le vrai problème c'est le
camouflet électoral de novembre dernier
quand la l'ancienne milice de l'armée la
usdp a été complètement rejetés dans les
yeux avec seulement 33 voix et il est
possible que le général de mines anglais
qui est quand même l'homme le plus
puissant qu'en qu'on en dise de la
birmanie même avant ce coup d'état les
tout simplement très très mal pris et
décider de resserrer un peu les rangs
[Musique]
on a peu d'informations puisque d'abord
quand le coup d'état a été déclarée
toutes les communications étaient
coupées l'internet a été coupé il ya une
peur qui s'est installée il ya des
mouchards il ya un système de
surveillance extrêmement développé mais
il ya un mouvement de désobéissance
civile qui est en train de se propager
notamment sur facebook sur internet sur
les réseaux sociaux
oui il ya effectivement les américains
la nouvelle administration américaine
qui a tapé du poing sur la table union
européenne à l'instant les pays voisins
mais les militaires birmans savent que
en ces temps de pandémie toute façon les
frontières sont fermées qu'est ce que va
faire l'administration américaine
notamment au conseil de sécurité pour
voter des sanctions quand l'allier
chinois très puissant va de toute façon
on mettra un veto donc les militaires
birmans ont fait un parfait
il va être très difficile de faire
pression sur sur eux donc on est
vraiment dans le retour d'une remise en
main très très très forte à des
militaires birmans